hey guys Pete here all right today I'm
gonna do a quick video about what we
know about the season 8 release date
there was some news today and we really
don't know I'll tell you that upfront
but there is some pretty good guesses we
can make at this point The Hollywood
Reporter put out an article where they
had talked to the programming president
at HBO KC boys because we've had this
rumor that it probably wouldn't come out
until 2019 so but basically happened was
we know that they're gonna start filming
in October but we learned that they're
gonna be filming all the way until late
August of 2018 as far as what sources
are saying and that could definitely fit
for the 2019 released it that's 16
months between seasons and even though
HBO wouldn't deny that they wouldn't
confirm it either so that's pretty much
saying yeah that's probably about right
so KC boys the programming president
said our production people are trying to
figure out a timeline for the shoot and
how much time the special effects take
he went on to say that the shooting is
complicated enough on different
continents with all the technical
aspects and the special effects are a
whole other production period that we're
trying to figure out that is a big
factor in this so we know that they're
going to be doing six episodes that has
been confirmed at this point and we also
heard a few months back that they're
actually going to be maybe all 80
minutes plus so we're looking at a bunch
of episodes that are gonna be about as
long as the season 7 finale was
considering that we're firmly in the
period of the war for the dawn that
makes you think that there's gonna be a
lot of post-production and a lot of CGI
necessary considering that the enemy in
one side of this war is more or less CGI
based and then we have the Dragons on
both sides and everything else that goes
along with that The Hollywood Reporter
article was the it was kind of
interesting to me because it appointed
out that this is not all that odd
nowadays several big shows once they got
to the size they were took long breaks
in between seasons so
we've kind of been getting used to this
but until this season game of Thrones
was always pretty much the same I know
this year the one year wait in between
seems like a really long time but that
was quickly forgotten once the season
started so 16 months sounds like forever
but if experience of this year is
anything to go off of I'd say people
will enjoy it one way or the other if
well no matter how long it takes I mean
we're getting into the grounds of
something that we haven't seen even in
the show we got a little taste of it in
the end of the season 7 finale and I
think it's safe to say that we can all
agree that something like that should
take some time and if they rushed it it
would probably take away from the
awesomeness the thing that really stands
out to me is that there is a lot of
stuff to still happen in six episodes I
mean there's like they say eight or nine
hours over those six episodes there's
still a lot to figure out in a way and
when I was thinking about this earlier
today I was kind of trying to think
because you have to imagine that they
decided on 13 episodes for the last two
seasons because they had these 13 things
that they wanted to tell different
battles different meetings you know all
the stuff we just saw and then they had
six more of these left for next season
and it kind of makes you wonder about
the actual layout of the individual
episodes and I'd be glad to hear what
you guys think about this too I mean
typically we would expect that the the
war for the dawn or the battle between
you know where the night King gets
taking out if that's what happens is
gonna be in the fifth episode and that
would leave two hours for the aftermath
but at the same time they're like
setting up all this other stuff that's
going down so it's really kind of
interesting to think about it like it
could actually happen faster the first
half could be the war for the dawn and
then the second half could be how they
put the pieces back together with
whoever's left or you know like I said
it could just be like always so yeah
it's kind of interesting to think about
we'll learn more once filming does start
if you followed my channel last year you
know that I follow that and I'll be
making regular videos during that time
because that's the best part you know
and we see the pictures and we try to
figure it out that
the speculation is a lot of fun of
course last year the leaks dropped and
then there was a big you know people
stopped caring about seeing this
production spoilers once they understood
what was gonna happen in the season and
hopefully we won't see that again this
year but the major points I guess would
be John and Danny's relationship what's
left of the Iron Throne obviously sir
she's gonna have to be taken out one way
or the other they're gonna have to put
together some kind of ruler to lead the
seven kingdoms post the war for the dawn
or however they do it I mean they might
split it up so that they have individual
leaders and the individual kingdoms but
I would you know I'm thinking about that
you know you know say they first two
episodes they just show them tearing
through things and we get a couple
fights that where a lot of people die
but the main characters escape or we get
a couple big deaths how does six
episodes look like especially if they're
two hours long it's a lot of fun I can't
wait to see you whenever this filming
gets underway we're not that far away
from that already so we should be
starting to get some ideas of who's
involved in what locations and all that
kind of stuff but it does look like to
me that it won't be till 2019 when we
actually see season eight sixteen months
sounds like a safe guesstimate based on
how long we know they're shooting if
they start shooting in October and they
go till August you have to imagine at
least four to six months in
post-production after they're done
filming so we got a long wait the long
night is on us for real let me know if
you have any questions about this stuff
it's pretty straightforward right now we
really won't know until we know we
didn't find out until when the season
that's gonna start this year till right
before actually but we'll keep guessing
we'll keep looking at what we know make
sure you like the video if you enjoyed
it make sure you subscribe to my channel
if you haven't already and set your
notifications because you're gonna want
to know when new videos come out
give me a follow on Twitter and my other
social media accounts where we can
interact over there thanks for watching
guys I'll talk to you soon